smart toys are popular holiday gifts but
consumer watchdogs warned of the risks
to children's privacy Wired's new
article is called don't get your kid an
internet-connected toy in that article
one privacy group says companies selling
Internet connected toys are quote
profiting by collecting and monetizing a
lot of sensitive information from your
kids the FBI issued a Safety Alert in
July about how smart toys can present
privacy concerns for children CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson is
editor-in-chief of Wired Nick good
morning morning their website calls
Internet connected toys hacker heaven
and you're starting to get freaked out
about privacy you say yeah so there's a
real discrepancy between the privacy
protections built in the most Internet
connected toys and the privacy
protections that you want for your
children
and that's because these toys aren't
sort of set up in general with the best
standards it's hard to update them to
patch things they're easily packed
there's tact they're starting to have
microphones and cameras which are a
nightmare and kids don't have defenses
against privacy invasions because they
haven't learned these things so we're
saying you got to be wary I was stunned
to see the FBI sent out a warning about
this how is this information being used
I know it's an intense warning it came
out in July and it's you know 17-point
warning saying hey we've had a bunch of
problems we've had Internet connected
toys that store information on the
clouds like your child's voice that can
then be hacked we have lots of these
toys that have been you know sort of
appropriated for botnets so be wary that
was an intense statement by them can we
switch to Apple about them admitting
that they had I mean in a way I said
earlier that it's genius but it's
annoying what do you say about this
right okay so what what we learned
yesterday is that the sort of the
conspiracy theories about Apple are true
that as your battery gets older as your
phone gets older they deliberately
degrade the processing speed so lots of
people in the internet said oh my god
they're doing that because they want you
to upgrade their phone they make your
phones worse and Apple came back with a
totally legitimate statement saying no
their lithium-ion batteries over time
they degrade if your battery has
degraded we have
to slow down the processing speed so
that your processing doesn't spike and
shut down your phone there's how easy is
it to replace a battery right so this is
the this is the counter right okay Apple
I believe your statement but like if
you're gonna degrade the performance of
the phone shouldn't be easy to swap out
the battery no it's not and the reason
it's not particularly on iPhones is
because Beautiful's I don't have a screw
in the back you can't just like take a
Phillips head screwdriver and put a new
battery and the battery is glued inside
they do that for design reasons they do
it for waterproofing reasons but you
would think that with this they would
make it easier to swap your batteries
and they should if you're gonna slow
down a phone because you have an old
battery you know where that is about it
now well they're telling us about it
because they got busted on reddit right
guys like I was why are they telling us
they should have just admitted it
upfront but they got busted on reddit
okay because I mean there are all these
forums that have been testing it and
they've kind of proved it and then so
Apple said yes but we do it for you and
again Apple statement it's it's
legitimate they're not making it up
right they are doing it to prevent spike
so your phone doesn't shut down like
that is a perfectly good reason it does
have perhaps the benefits Apple that it
makes you want to upgrade your phone
nick quickly if you want to buy an
internet-connected toy for your kid this
year what do you do to make sure it's
safe you should read the privacy
settings you should make its turrets
from responsible manufacturer and there
is a list of FTC approved companies that
will certify toys saying that they
follow best practices once you set it up
you should make sure to update it and
you should be wary about things with
cameras and microphone oh my god I
barely have enough time to wrap the
present website and read the privacy
Nora don't buy anything into camera
something on our website about it we put
something on Twitter right now with the
FTC link